There's that and there's also the,
the looming specter of the mass shooter.
It's just so fucking common these days.
It seems like every three or four months,
there's a new instance how
many times per cent happened.
Perception is a bitch,
but the reality is the absolute
reality is they have happened.
They are horrific and there's more of
them here than anywhere else in the world.
That's reality.
But here's the hall was another good.
So when you say that you're talking
about the develop world. Correct,
because that's usually the
caveat they like to play with it.
There's no mass shootings
in the undeveloped world is
people don't just go into
a fucking mall and shoot people
up with winches. It's rare.
Very rare the people take it happens
more than people realize and just doesn't
get reported on about it. How many
people die in Chicago on the weekend?
Over a weekend. It doesn't get reported.
That's true. But then we live in America.
We through complete access
to information that is true,
but it's a different kind of violence
because it's people that are actively
trying to get people that are actively
trying to get them. It's gang violence,
whereas school shootings are complete.
Innocent school shootings are the worst,
right?
Because it's a child and some fucking
psycho decides to make the most noise
possible by going into a
school and shooting it up.
That's the scariest and the worst
for most people from owning.
When you think about gang violence,
you say, well, that's violent.
It's terrible that people got shot,
but it's people that are trying
to shoot each other. All right,
so then when I tell you that the remaining
homicides in this country right at
30,000 number that I gave you annually,
over 80% of that is gang violence.
Okay.
That's crazy to think about
leaving. Yeah, I believe you,
but it's when you see Sandy Hook,
when you see Parkland,
when you see any that the shooting in
Colorado, Aurora in the movie theater,
when you see these mass shootings,
these are what terrify people. Yeah.
People are not necessarily terrified
of the gang violence in Chicago.
You know what?
I'm going to Chicago in a couple of
months and not one fucking person has
brought up, hey man, it plays a war zone.
Everybody's like, oh, I love Chicago.
You're going to get deep dish pizza like
nobody gives a fuck. Is that what it is
and no, I'm not going to the south
side there. See, that's the thing.
I just went to Chicago. It was just in
Chicago. Paul was here and they were like,
well, you locked and loaded. Did you
wear a vest? Yes, I'm dead serious.
I got all those questions. What?
I said I was going to Chicago.
Those are the first things people told
me. Now, granted I did go to south side.
I did. Yeah, we did. Well, you nervous
when you're walking around? I was nervous.
I'm not superman, man, so
when you're walking around,
he's strapped a not in Chicago
because it's illegal for me to be.
That's what's crazy is that Chicago has
really strict gun laws and that they
don't work at all. I was driving down the
road where there were like six, seven,
eight dudes who jumped in front of the
car when we drove that because we didn't
look like we belonged there.
And I'm positive every
single one of them had a gun.
They jumped in front of the car.
Well they didn't like the little lob,
their bodies in front of the
car. But you know, you look,
you see a call this unfamiliar to
drive it down the side streets.
So they try to stop you. Uh,
they didn't try to stop me,
I think just trying to figure out who
the hell we were or they were just trying
to service. Ah, yeah. Ah,
so it's Kinda one of those
things, right. But then again,
when you're driving around,
you're driving down the side street,
south side Chicago, but go pros on
the car. Yeah. Oh, that's true. Yeah.
Right, right. So you
kind of have that. Um,
so we all agree that the gun violence,
especially in terms of mass shootings
is one of the biggest problems that we
have in terms of like a horrific
public image problem. Right? It's, uh,
it's, it's something that you see
in the, in every I'm, when I'm,
when I say public image, I should, what
I should, I should re re phrase that.
What I mean is like public
perception problem. Like you,
you see it and it's just death and
violence and children and innocence and we
as,
as people I think consider the death
of innocence to be one of the most
egregious in horrific deaths. Absolutely.
I think we both agree on. Absolutely. So,
so that's 100% across the board.
I think with any decent person,
these mass shootings are horrific.
I think in my opinion the,
the,
the number one aspect of the argument
that's not being discussed is the mental
health aspect of it.
Are you opposed to more
screening of people to get guns?
Yes and no. Yes and no. Yeah. Okay.
Yes. And that in an ideal world,
if we could minority report
it and figure it out,
who do you mean minority report?
I mean just like check to see if they're
on metal, mental health medication.
But I mean we, we currently have,
we'll see it. Here's the thing.
This slippery slope with that too.
So what,
what constitutes somebody being on mental
health medication that's prohibitive,
right?
What if I,
what if I deal with anxiety if I'm on
Xanax prescribed cause that prevent me
from owning a firearm.
It's a good question.
In California for the longest
time they were trying to make it,
if he had a medical marijuana
card you could no firearm.
I think they were doing that federally.
I think that there was a federal thing
that if you had a legal medical marijuana
card that they were trying to prevent
people they were trying to prevent both
from,
they were trying to try to cripple the
medical marijuana industry because they
knew that people want it done.
Because to be honest, it's,
it's intellectually dishonest.
If I can,
if I can go to the store with a
gun on me and buy alcohol, right?
Like, and you know me, I'm the,
I don't even smoke. Right, right.
But let's just be honest
about it. Like alcohol, weed,
I mean I think utilizing that as a
prohibitive means to own a firearm.
I think it's, that is true. But
if you were under the influence,
some of the Shit I got in this studio.
No, no, no. You'd be super paranoid.
I didn't under a gun and say I
didn't say under the influence.
I said if I cause all the,
all the marijuana card does
is allow you to buy it.
No 100% but I'm saying that is an issue.
If you're under the influence and you have
a gun, right? Yeah. But I'm allowed to.
I, but I have you go to my house right
now, I have all types of whiskeys at home.
Right? Yeah. Baby. But if you're under
the influence, right? Yeah. But yeah, no,
I can't, I can't carry a firearm
and drunk. Right. You can't,
you shouldn't be drunk with a gun. You
shouldn't be high as fuck with the gun.
Neither one of those are good ideas
and nor should you be driving. Right.
Nor should you be driving.
So should you be on Xanax with a gun?
That's a question I don't know the
answer to because I've never had Xanax.
Exactly. Me Neither. I
don't know what it's like,
but I do know that there's been people
that have killed people when they were on
Xanax. And you know, that guy in
Vegas does the shooter in Vegas.
That guy was on anti anxiety
medication. I didn't know that. Um,
Chris Cornell was on antiemetic anti
anxiety medication when he killed himself.
Um, look, it's got a profound effect
on some individuals and it's not,
it's not uniform the way it affects you.
It might change with different,
totally different. It's a
different thing. I know,
I know tons of people who are on it.
Yeah, I do as well. And they respond,
like you said, they respond to it
differently and I know tons of people on,
or it will also drink while they're on
it, which you're not supposed to do. Yeah.
And that, that's not good
either. Yeah. With them with,
so screening with the screening component,
right.
You gotta be careful because
what it then does, it's like,
it becomes a de facto way of preventing
people to own firearms arbitrarily.
Right. So it was like,
oh, well you have anxiety.
Or even even somebody who was
maybe dealing with PTSD, right?
Not everybody dealing with
PTSD as a potential murderous,
ravenous hundred percent person who just
going to go out and kill people. Um,
so with the screening component,
that's why I say yes or no. Right?
If you can find a way,
if you can find a way to establish a scar,
a mental screening, but even then,
no, because there's, there's a,
there's a due process
aspect to it as well, right?
So you can't prevent me from owning and
you can't prevent me from exercising a
right. If I haven't done something to
absolve myself from being able to do that
legally. Right. Okay. So what if they
come to your house and you've got,
let's say you've got like a cork board
up and you've got all these pictures of
schools and fucking arrows pointing to
the emergency exits and plans of how to
block things off and then pictures of
Jodie foster and pictures of serial
killers up everywhere and you're on anti
anxiety medications and the cops talked
to you and your fucking squirrely is
hell, you haven't done anything now. Yeah.
[inaudible] then if you can't arrest me,
arrest can't. If you can't arrest me for,
for, for crime or possibly attempting
to cause like, like in Italy,
like the legal standard is like taking
substantial act to commit a crime even
though you don't do it.
That's attempted. Right.
Did you hear about the kid that got kicked
out of school? Um, what was the school?
He was an agent. Kid died, his hair
blonde, started collecting bullets,
got a semiautomatic rifle.
His friends started freaking
out. They called the cops.
Cops came to visit him. He bought another
rifle and I believe they deported him.
They deported them for reasons not
having to do with the firearms.
They deported him for reasons that he
wasn't actually going to climb anymore on
a green card or visa.
I believe the way the sheriff's were
framing it was they deported him because
they wanted this fucking psycho out of
the country and they think that they
might've prevented a crime. They
probably did, but they still had,
they still had to establish a
legal basis for deporting him.
All they had was that, that
he didn't go to class. Yeah,
I mean that's something you've done.
I've done. Yeah. I mean everybody,
but then again, he wasn't a citizen.
Right. So, and that was, that was the,
that was a requirement for him to
continue to be here. But it was really,
it was kind of like how I got like
Al Capone, you know, like God,
I could Capone my tax evasion by way
of, you know. Right, right, right.
But he really had guns
and was acting crazy.
And that's why the kids that
were friends with them called,
and that's why they acted and they
just found that loophole. Yeah.
So what do you do with someone like
that? Other than that, I mean, this guy,
we had something. What if
this kid was still going to
school? I mean, it, it'd be,
it'd be pretty bad. Pretty bad.
But, but then again, we still,
we still have our laws for
a reason, right? We have,
we have our inherent rights for a reason.
We have to do process for a reason
because if we didn't have those right,
anyone could just come up and
say, man, you know what I saw?
I saw calling on the war
on Instagram the other day,
he posted a picture of a gun,
didn't,
he was like cursing people out
because they're making fun of them.
The water he was drinking.
And so, you know what?
Somebody needs to go check on
him and make sure he's okay.
And it's my monies to go and take his
guns away from him. Right. You've got to,
there's got to be due process. I
appreciate that. And I agree with you and,
and it's,
it's unfortunate in that
some people may slip through the cracks,
but,
but I can't arrest someone for something
that they haven't done yet. Right.
You just, you just can't. Well, I agree.
And so that's where we are right now.
So then, so then that, now we're
getting to the complexities, the hard,
the hard questions, right? What do we do?
How do we put something in place to
catch the people who do happen to fall
between the cracks, right? So then you
go, okay, try to keep, oh, sorry. Yeah,
I'm moving. I don't know if you
seen materials. I'm like hydro,
um, the complexities. Yeah.
It's, it's a very complex issue,
which is why we're not largely not having
it and we're having it here because no
one wants to have this conversation on
the national scene because it's hard and
it doesn't make for great sound bite
and it doesn't make for good TV. Hmm.